[Music]
what happens when a group of the world's
greatest minds gifted with wealth beyond
our imagination
buys a sprawling waterfront property in
toronto they make plans for a 14.3
billion dollar futuristic city that's
what
sidewalk labs released its master
innovation and development plans to turn
a chunk of toronto's lake ontario
shoreline
into the most futuristic city in the
world it would result in over 93 000
jobs and a better standard of living for
its residents and today
we're going to take a peek inside
welcome back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you
subscribe and ring the bell so you never
miss a video from us
google x sidewalk smart city
alphabet an umbrella company that
includes google and sidewalk labs is now
creating the world's first
smart city in toronto canada it seeks to
provide technological solutions to
improve citizens lives
there will be two key areas quaiside
which is along the shorelines of lake
ontario and features houses shops and
offices
the first office here of course will be
google's the second area is the river
district an area of 152 acres featuring
five neighborhoods surrounding the don
river now on the housing front there's a
plan for a collection of new mixed-use
buildings
up to 30 stories tall the project would
cost around 3.9 billion dollars and
would use
mass timber and modular components made
in the local factory owned by sidewalk
labs
to get around the city will have a 1.2
billion dollar light rail
extension which would connect the
neighborhoods to mass transit before the
new residents move in
it would cut down on the need for
residents to own a car and it would be
safe and affordable
canada is known for its somewhat
overwhelming winters
you've heard the jokes well the hyper
local weather sensors would detect an
oncoming snowstorm and heat up the snow
melting pavements it would keep the
streets clear for pedestrians and
cyclists as well as autonomous delivery
robots
it's all going to be connected heavily
monitored and pretty much
self-regulating wi-fi would be available
for everyone throughout the city for
free and sensors around the area would
collect data on the energy usage
traffic patterns and much much more to
ensure you as a resident lead the most
comfortable life possible what's more
the city is going to be climate positive
aka netting a sub-zero carbon footprint
but we already expected that right
in toronto sidewalk labs shows a picture
of a world with intelligent
pay-as-you-throw garbage chutes that
separate your plastic from papers for
you
the city would charge households by
waste and apps would tell residents when
chairs on the waterfront were open
so residents can get approvals for block
party permits in addition
traffic signals will auto calibrate to
ease pedestrian congestion during public
events and rush hours the director of
sidewalk labs
eric jaffe was primarily responsible for
this impressive proposal he expects or
rather hopes
that more cities around the world will
pick up on this blueprint and use it for
themselves
one of those ideas is for a factory
built housing it helps developers
complete their projects reliably
on time and at a lower cost critique and
government approval
before all that though government
officials have to scrutinize and approve
sidewalk lab's master plan or not and
don't expect the process to be a snap
some of the major elements of the
project have shifted over time and so
have the targets of the project's
detractors
when waterfront toronto the
government-appointed non-profit
developer of toronto's eastern shore
chose sidewalk labs to plan their smart
city development the most controversial
point of the plan was the idea that a
google sister company planned to harvest
data in public space
over time sidewalk labs was criticized
for not revealing how they would use the
data and who would control it
and for a while there the canadian civil
liberties association sued the
government to stop the project
so sure sidewalk labs dreamt of making a
section of toronto a futuristic city
the likes of which we've only ever seen
in science fiction but skeptics saw a
darker side
thousands of cameras monitoring streets
and data from every household being
taken and used this was one among many
things their ceo
sundar pachai had to testify about when
he was called to congress and pretty
much
grilled for three and a half hours for
those reasons and
perhaps others the sidewalk toronto
project was abandoned in may of 2020 to
give way for a new kind of city
as exciting as the new city would have
been we still lost the chance to have an
internet first community which promised
affordable internet and precise data on
our carbon footprint and consumption
to live more sustainable lifestyles we
lost a fully integrated transport system
social housing 93 000 jobs and finally
a green city initiative but bigger
things are to come
the new city in toronto now
quayside will have a new different kind
of development the government calls for
proposals when google and toronto parted
ways and these new plans seem to center
on affordability
low carbon design and an emphasis on
local and minority-owned businesses
instead of what some have called a
dystopian nightmare there's a lot to be
done
so far the plans only include glossy
renderings of wooden skyscrapers and the
integration of elements of lake ontario
into parks and recreational areas
but one thing's for sure it won't be a
google smart city
would you want to live in a google city
let us know in the comments
and if you enjoyed this video hit the
like button and check out more on the
simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time